kamala harris following joe biden's lead
and refusing to answer whether democrats
will pack the supreme court if they win
the election in november
bp pence quickly calling her out they'd
like to know if you and joe biden are
going to
pack the supreme court if you don't get
your way in this nomination
let's talk about that you once again
gave a non-answer joe biden gave him
anonymous trying to answer you american
people deserve a straight answer yeah
let's talk about pac in the court then
let's talk about that i just want the
record reflect she never answered the
question
so i think maybe the next debate joe
biden will answer the question but i
think the american people know the
answer
and biden refusing to answer the
question again on the campaign trail
today
saying he will give his opinion on court
packing after
the election so dana that's not a no
it's not a no we're not going to
pack the court it's a maybe we will i
thought that mike pence
prosecuted that case very very well i
think that her
laughter in that instance was a little
bit about nerves it is really
unbelievable
that at this point they still don't have
an answer but now because we had joe
biden
saying again today actually i'm going to
wait until after the election
two things on that one i think that on
an issue that important that the
american people are being asked to
help decide their fate for the next four
years or beyond
um that that is an issue that really
they deserve to have an answer on
i think the fact that they are not
answering it means that the answer
is yes i mean that's that's what you
obviously you have to conclude that it's
yes
the second thing i want to bring up
though is i don't think joe biden is
really actually for
packing the court i don't think he is
yeah but what would happen
if he said that he's not what what
happened if he actually took a
principled stand and he led
on the issue would that mean that all
the
people on the left that that are in this
marriage of convenience this tenuous
truce
decide you know what it's not even worth
it yeah they don't want to vote for him
anyway and they're struggling to do it
greg
senator harris accused the trump
administration of racism for daring to
fill
uh judicial nomination seats as her
answer to the court packing
that's basically that that last club in
your golf bag
you know it's like if you got nothing
just pull out the old race club
and see if you can get out of the uh out
of the um the rough
the rough thank you why was that moment
so important
because it showed you that she didn't
look
presidential she didn't even look or
sound
senatorial and she's a senator like i
said i mean i
i picked her i i i thought she was going
to be the nominee and i thought she was
going to be the vp choice
but man it's like all this time if they
didn't prep her she just seemed so
lightweight so this is a huge win for
trump
and even though it was pence it's a huge
win for trump because she's not really
she may be the number two spot but they
they're
biden is relying on her pretending or
becoming the number one spot
she's actually running for number one
yeah and they just showed that she can't
be number one
not in this current state but the reason
why she's never comfortable and this is
why she wasn't a good
presidential candidate is because she
doesn't know where she stands on the
issues in terms of principle because she
has changed them so many times juan
and she's on the record saying she's
willing to get rid of the filibuster in
order to pack the supreme court but now
doesn't want to answer the question
you know i just find this whole
discussion here on the five so one-sided
because it was pence
who couldn't say to the most
consequential question of the night
will you respect the results of the
election he couldn't just say yes
absolutely no he said well let's see how
the election i mean that's crazy should
they talk
no should they pack the quarter yes or
no let me just say i if it was up to me
if it was up to me here's how i would
have answered it and by the way
i thought she did not do a good job on
that question she won the debate but she
didn't do a good job on that question
i think she should have quickly pivoted
and said katie
you know wait a second let's talk about
not only the fact that the judges who've
been put on the court are all white men
racist but less but let's talk about the
fact that you're having a rushed process
to force
a nominee onto the court while americans
are voting while elections taking place
for the president what about clinton's
comments and let's
let's look at how the republicans have
corrupted
this process and most americans would
have agreed
with kamala harris that this is absolute
root political prosperity politics
and that should be done i guess clarence
in fact i think it's crazy that trump
prioritizes barrett
over getting relief for our economy okay
well
jessie judge amy coney barrett is not a
white man
so apparently that argument doesn't
stand under
who she is did clarence thomas nominated
by donald trump no
you said on the court he's no no no
donald trump
this is what she was speaking about last
night that if you look at donald trump's
nominations largely
as a debate moderator i'm giving the
floor to jesse largely white men
is not a third woman so that counts for
something juan
and before she grabbed the race club
greg yes
she lied about honest abe now if you lie
about lincoln
i think that just disqualifies you for
running for the vp
this is what she said she said abe
didn't nominate anybody for the supreme
court before the election because
he thought he should wait until after
the voters had to say
she made that up out of thin air in fact
history shows
that the reason he didn't nominate
someone right away was because the
senate wasn't in session
the second the senate came back in
session he nominated chase
chase was confirmed to be justice the
same day
and that's what happened so it was a lot
of lies
at of kamala it was the fine people hoax
it was trump
disbanded the pandemic unit out of the
nsc
it was this lie it was he didn't
denounce white supremacy
lied about lincoln thank you for
analyzing thank you for the history
lesson jesse we appreciate